so machine learning what does machine
learning machine learning really is
teaching machines how to find patterns
in large amounts of data the way it
works is you've got a black box think of
this as just this the set of algorithms
in the center that that can turn a mass
of unstructured data or a massive
confusing data into something which is
less confusing and more structured so
what happens is you basically tell the
machine i'm going to give you all this
input on this side and i'm going to tell
you what the input should look like
post-processing on this side so you kind
of give it the hint and what it does the
machine says okay well how do i get from
point A to point B and that built in
essence a pattern to say okay when I see
all this data if I to get to this
structured set of data I have to do all
these computations the middle to move it
from unstructured or messy too
structured and beautiful and that can
apply not just to data compiled anything
you can it can apply to faces it can
apply two types of cats whatever might
be you're basically saying hey machine
this is a cat and so this is okay when I
see two eyes and a little pink nose and
attend some whiskers doesn't actually
say it's but that's what it's worth
thinking then that is a cat so you teach
machines in essence to recognize
patterns in data in pictures and where
it might be so that's machine learning
basically you're in essence helping
machines find patterns and masses
amounts of data how does it apply to
things like natural language well now
the beauty of machine learning the
beauty of things called deep neural
networks allow in essence machines to
not think like humans that's too much of
a stretch but certainly operate in the
same way that we operate the same way
that for example when you're a child you
might see a ball on the floor you know
what it's called you don't know how it's
you know how its constructed anything
else but over time people as you're
walking around the house your mom or
your dad will say look at that ball or
go get the ball and so what's happening
is over time you're getting reinforced
that when you see an object in the floor
that is stationary and has a certain
circumference and looks a certain way
you begin to understand how that's
that's a ball because you've heard it
over and over again machine learning and
natural image processing operates much
the same way except instead of having
your mom or dad point of the thing and
say that's a ball three or four times
machines down
now have trillions of observations about
the real world so they can learn these
things much much faster so for NLP it's
it's critical because our ability to
interact with search really is
predicated on the system's understanding
of what it is we are asking
traditionally again machines would
return back results or web pages based
on the keywords that we put into the box
but if I were to ask a search engine why
is there no Jaguar in this room today we
would get back five and a half million
results of for that question with none
of which make any sense of course with
natural language suddenly because the
search systems understand what a Jaguar
is it's a cards a sports team I think
it's an it's an animal to mammal of some
sort it understands what a room is
understands the construct of that
sentence when you ask a search engine in
the very near future why is it no Jaguar
in this room the response will not be
5.6 million results it'll be a question
back to you saying what do you mean like
are you asking why there's no Jaguar car
in this room are you asking why there is
no Jaguar animal in this room and then
it could be said oh no I yes I meant the
fort the second one why was it a Jaguar
animal in this room and because again
the search engine understands what a
Jaguar is and the animal is and where
they usually live and they would say
well because you're not in a jungle and
jaguars generally don't live in in
conference rooms like this and so NLP
becomes very exciting because it's it's
it's modeled on the notion that the
system that the search system
understands the physical world
everything in it and how all those
things relate to each other and so
suddenly now you begin to be able to
engage in dialogue just as you and I
would do as humans when we have a
question about meeting your intent or
context we engage in clarifying
questions that's what will happen with
NLP and search and it's already
happening today in certain cases
you